vous remportez cette ville malgré les
alliances qui ont été nouées contre vous
finalement
oui alors j'ai pas entendu votre
question en tout cas pour dire que je
remercie du fond du cœur tous les
morpasiens qui qui m'ont fait confiance
ce soir c'est la victoire du renouveau
la victoire de l'alternance morp qui
était géré par la même équipe depuis
1989 donc voilà c'est un SIG fort qui a
été envoyé euh qui a été envoyé par les
morpasiens j'en suis ravi je suis
heureux pour les morpasiens je serai le
maire de tous les morpas bien voilà je
vais euh je vais maintenant m'atteler à
à travailler sur tous les dossiers la
protection du cadre de vie euh la
stabilité fiscale pendant 6 ans voilà je
ferai tout pour en tout cas améliorer le
quotidien des des morpasiens c'est aussi
la victoire de l'intégrité de
l'honnêteté de la droiture nous n'avons
cédé à aucune compromission dans cette
campagne et voilà c'est vraiment la
victoire que les morpasiens ment et j'en
suis vraiment heureux pour eux parce que
pour morpa euh voilà moi qui suis un
enfant de morpas j'en suis vraiment
extrêmement heureux je remercie
également tous mes soutiens toute mon
équipe du fond du cœur parce que sans
elle je n'aurais rien pu faire je
remercie tous mes soutiens politiques
notamment le maire d'éencour mais aussi
Philippe benasaya le nouveau maire de
boonarti voilà ils m'ont aidé aussi
pendant cette campagne j'en suis très
satisfait voilà très heureux je remercie
jean-fédéric poisson mon député qui m'a
citeu jusqu'au bout euh voilà Monsieur
lumè votre premier sentiment sur cette
victoire vous êtes heureux ou alors vous
déoncez l'abstention comme dans votre
discours il y a quelques minutes oui je
fais cette remarque toujours 55 % de de
mes con citoyens ne sont pas venus voter
voilà c'est je le regrette en tant en
tant que républicain et en tant que
démocrate après c'est d'abord une une
victoire pour retenir le le mot nous
sommes reconduits pour 6 ans avec toute
l'équipe moi je constate aussi que
l'ensemble de la gauche à trap fait 70 %
des voix et donc traap reste encré dans
dans son histoire de ville ouvrière et
du et de ville de gauche bah je crois
que d'abord il faut prendre acte de la
victoire de Bernard Debin c'est la règle
en démocratie les saint-syriens ont
choisi de de le reconduire ce que je
peux constater quand même c'est qu'il
est reconduit avec moins d'un
saint-syrien sur deux qui perd de points
par rapport à son élection du premier
tour de 2008 voilà c'est c'est ça le
résultat des urnes alors de notre côté
34 et ben dans un contexte
particulièrement difficile au niveau
gouvernemental on maintient nos
positions et donc on va avoir nos six
élus au conseil municipal un élu qui
siégera à la communauté d'agglomération
et les saint-sériens peuvent compter sur
nous pour qu'on continue à faire le
travail qu'on fait depuis 6 ans et je
leur donne rendez-vous tout au long de
la mandature et ce qui relève de notre
intercommunalité ça suppose de parler
projet je voudrais rappeler aussi que
demain même avec le changement li à la
loi et le fait qu'on aura peut-être deux
délégués de plus de droite que de gauche
il n'en reste pas moins qu'il faut faire
fonctionner un conseil des maires où
nous aurons SEP maires quatre qui sont
avec une sensibilité de gauche et trois
avec une sensibilité de droite il faudra
faire fonctionner des votes aussi avec
certaines délibérations qui se prennent
à la majorité qualifiée et vous voyez
quand tout à l'heure monsieur Fourgous
disait que la casquie était trop
politisée je pense que celui qui la
politise le plus celui qui sera le plus
à créer l'éclivage celui qui cherchera
non pas à regarder comment on fonctionne
tous ensemble mais qui essa au contraire
d'aller dans le sens de ce qu'il disait
tout à l'heure c'est peut-être monsieur
Fourgous je le dis simplement pour avoir
mais vous m'excuserez je vais même
passer la
paroleivux répondre je peux répondre
quand même parce
que c'est un peu audacieux vous qui êtes
très politisé la casqu qui est classé
comme la plus politisée en Île de France
enfin écoutez monsieur amont monsieur
amont qui qui qui qui qui a fait partir
monsieur Cadalbert dans des conditions
dans des conditions quand même très très
vraiment très très très peu je dirais
sur le plan moral ça POS un problème
enfin qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
présidence on a vu ce système où
Monsieur amont vous propose un po de
sénateur ensuite vous enlevez monsieur
Cadalbert de votre de votre liste de
votre liste laissez-moi terminer
laissez-moi je vous ai pas coupé je ne
vous ai pas coupé moi il vous propose un
poste de un poste de sénateur VO pour
pour ne pas mettre monsieur Cadalbert
sur votre liste monsieur calberttait
était quelqu'un de consensuel je j'ai
beaucoup de respect pourbiette bon c'est
c'est c'est la démocratie c'est un jour
on y passera tous ici Monsieur Bonon
c'est la règle du jeu bon vous êtes le
grand battu ce soir c'est une immense
déception j'imagine pour vous éz grand
battu non parce que j'ai quand même eu
2340 électeurs qui se sont portés sur ma
liste avec un écart très faible pour le
moment qui est de 15 voix il y a un
bureau de vote qui doit être recompté
hein et puis ce que je
peux dire aussi c'est qu'on examinera
les irrégalités qu'on a
pu deviner et constater dans cette dans
cette campagne c'était d'ailleurs votre
message dans votre discours il y a
quelques minutes sur l'estrade au sein
de la mairie vous notez sur cette
campagne des irrégularités surtout une
campagne assez agressive qui a peut-être
pu vous desservir oui qu'elle soit
agressive je dirais que c'est le jeu
hein mais qu'il y ait des irrégularités
non ça ce n'est pas admissible dans le
jeu démocratique quel est l'avenir pour
vous après cette déception pour
l'instant en tout cas écoutez c'est de
conserver la dynamique d' équipe
extraordinaire qui est autour de moi qui
s'investira au sein du conseil municipal
en donnant vraiment ses ses compétences
hein il y aura SEP conseillers
municipaux et puis au niveau de la
communé d' aussi euh où moi-même je
continuerai à siéger et là dans un avec
un nouvel élan une nouvelle gouvernance
puisque la majorité de laakaski change
et qu'il y a matière je crois à
travailler et à lancer cette casquille
vraiment au service de tous et au
service de son bassin de vie oui tout à
fait Alexandra Rosetti est élu avec 15
voix d'avance ce soir sur ce second tour
à voisin broteneux elle est à mes côté
le nouveau maire la nouvelle maire de de
voisin Bretonneux j'imagine que la la
sensation de joie est immense ce soir
euh oui oui oui bah oui c'était quand
même serré donc c'était pas gagné et
donc je suis effectivement très ému
voilà il y avait seulement 15 vois
d'écart ça s'est joué jusqu'au dernier
comptage on a compté on a compté le
stress a dû être jusqu'à la dernière
minute omniprésent oui c'est assz
incroyable ce va vien de voix + 3 15 et
cetera c'est assez hallucinant donc ça
veut dire que ben c'est un score
extrêmement serré et ça veut dire que
les Vinois se sont quand même mobilisés
pour élire leur nouveau m la nouvelle
équipe municipale qui va diriger la
ville ces six prochaines années va
s'occuper de quel dossier en priorité
vous avez déjà des dossiers prioritaires
oui les dossiers prioritaires je crois
c'est ce qu'on a entendu sur le terrain
beaucoup c'est tout ce qui concerne la
circulation ce qui concerne
l'aménagement de la ville ça je crois
que les gens ont beaucoup d'attente à ce
sujet et donc c'est quelque chose dont
on va s'emparer immédiatement